Hi. I'm Geoff Donaker. I live here in the Bay
Area. California Bay Area and I have red green color blindness.
>> OK, so red green color blindness. We, you know, just sort
of heard about that for the first time in the course, and
we're learning a bit more about the inheritance patterns. What is red
green color blindness? What does it mean to be red green color blind?
>> Well, to me, what it means is that I often
mix up colors that have red in them. And so in particular,
I mix up reds and browns and sometimes browns and greens, because I'm
not seeing the red correctly in those. Sometimes it can even show up in
the form of blues and purples. I'm sort of seeing them all as about
the same, and in fact, you know, they may look different to other people.
>> So, would be accurate in saying, just, they kind of
look like darker colors or is it something about the shade maybe?
>> I'm not really sure. I think that the way
to think about it, you know, for me is that,
sometimes what you may be seeing is, is the
red in a particular orange for instance. To me I'm
not seeing the red the same way you are,
so I'm seeing it maybe like a dark yellow. and
so I certainly see the world in a vibrant
colorful way, and it's not like black and white or
anything like that. I just see it differently than
everybody else who doesn't see it in red, green color.
>> It's such a great like, literal and metaphorical statement. I think a lot
of people do go through life thinking that,
you know, the assumption, this is the color vision,
this is the vision I have, but not
everybody literally sees the world in the same spectrum.
>> That's right.
>> When did you first know that you have red green color blindness?
>> You know, I don't really remember. It was when I was a
really young child. my uncle had been red green color blind, and then actually
my mom's uncle as well. So I think I inherited it from her
side. And so when I was a little kid, she recognized that I might
be color blind, or had this perpensity. And so
she had me tested at, you know, one of the
eye doctors with looking at the little bubble charts with
colors that you may remember having taken at some point.
>> Sure and for anybody who may not be familiar with
those what can, can you describe that bubble chart a little more?
>> Sure it's basically a lot of little
dots, and those dots typically show some sort of
a picture, character, letter that a red green color
blind person may not be able to pick out
the particular picture or letter that everybody else,
you know, they, it pops out. So for
instance, back to my, yellow, orange analogy. you
know, you may have two different shades of
orange in there that to you look really
obviously different, and to me look actually about
the same. So I'm not seeing that letter
that's popping out of the picture and you are.
>> so as you've grown up, and even now as an
adult how does red green color blindness affect your daily life?
Do you have, what kind of special, if anything
sort of interactions you have to go through to accommodate?
>> You know, not much. when I clothes shop I, you know, online certainly helps
these days because the colors are all labeled.
you know when I go clothes shopping in
the store, I'll often ask the retail person just for sanity check. What color is
this? If it's blue, I'm generally pretty sure
I'm okay, or black or things like that.
but if I'm getting something that's in the green spectrum,
you know, I'll want a sanity check that it, it's
what I think it is, and it's not some version
of orange or something that people are going to comment on.
>> Mm-hm.
>> so that's one way, you know, another way is just periodically things that
look camouflaged to me won't be camouflaged
to other people, so for instance, you
know, my kids the other day were playing with an orange ball in the
yard. And to me when they dropped it in the grass, it was almost
camouflage in the grass. And you know they thought that was the funniest thing
in the world. Cause to them this orange was just totally popping off the lawn.
>> Have you ever not been able to participate
in something or anything because of the color blindness
or anything like that? Or, or you've pretty much
always been able to find some work around if it
was an issue, you could, you know, it was
always doable? Yeah, I mean as a general statement
it's really never been a big deal. I certainly
remember a couple of times as a kid where I
felt a little left out or picked on during art projects at school where,
you know inevitably I picked the wrong color. Where you were supposed to be
something that was brown and I picked green, or something like that nature, and
other kids would tease me and, I, yeah. I really remember maybe two or
three of these incidents, but you certainly
work around it, and somebody points you
to the right color, and you keep moving. so, never been a big deal
by any means, but, you know, there's certainly a little bit of that, like,
you are a little bit different from the way everybody else is seeing it.
>> if someone's watching this, and, you know, they're
like, oh, you know, I wonder if I'm color
blind, or maybe someone's recently found out they are,
or someone they know is. What advice would you
give to somebody who may have recently found out
that, you know, they are red green color blind?
And of course there are other kinds of color
blindness too. what advice would you give to them?
>> I don't know. I guess first point would simply
be it's not that big a deal. So, you know,
roll with it and enjoy the fact that you're seeing the world
in a slightly different color hue than everybody else is. and then the
other one would be, when you're picking clothes, ask a friend or the
sales associate at the store just so that you know what you're buying.
>>
[LAUGH]
sure